ce qu'il faut c'est qu'ils ont sur le
pré noir tu vois pas bien dedans tu
prends pas tu prends que la ville au
milieu tu reste bien que sur la bible et
tu en parles autre chose à l'extérieur
que les empreintes dentaires
l'accueillir pour le gros camion là
c'est un gars là-bas générale au milieu
là rien donc récupère la avec la balle
jaune un ouais c'est cela qui est loin
de remplir le câble les avions sont dans
l'ombre
en attendant j'en passe pas cela ceux
qui sont là regarde attaque au genou a
vu le petit rond là les camions qui font
la queue
ils ont remplacé la mecque par la grue
en toi voilà on voit bien que sur le
bien de te faire le dos rond adducteurs
tu t'écartes pas vu
chaque année on commence à bouger à
attendre avant de charger un camion est
sur une lancée passer dessus d'ailleurs
et pas sur celui là toi il recule peut
pas tout et tout de suite et en ce
moment on le voit atteindre à temps un
bel et bien sûr aucun wikipizz à téthieu
d'emprunt mais en fait elle peur dans
leur forêt
avec camions en ligne 14 avec quatre
camions en ligne plateforme voit la
jolie flamand ouais
selon l'historien ne date pas vraiment
dans le soleil du franc je lis ne
regarde pas bien le peuple prend des
gens bien voilà à peu près ce que le 2
et le des cadres et un perdant j'espère
c'est bien ça les 4-14 génial moi je le
prends assez large en mettant le rond à
goa doha à gauche de l'image à droite et
moi j'ai les peu les deux files de
camions la vallée par tous les types de
camions qui reculent pour se mettre
dedans tu vois je serai plus large que
ça je sais pas gérer père vers pas à
bertoua voilà voilà un copte a
exactement voilà voilà voilà comme ça
voilà descends descends descends et sans
solution voilà ça fera sous les camions
en lice de la dotant 8 devant toi il
reste encore deux enfants vertikal 1
les gens disent encore deux ans encore
voilà lors la fait pas 30 voilà voilà
voilà voilà la t te revoilà voilà encore
voilà ta de les y voilà
tu sais c'est le gros les corps et les
la voilà comme ça voilà c'est quatre
fois plus que sur est comme ça va la
placer pour cet excellent dans l'art est
dans voilà tous les camions qui bouge
dans tous les sens où elle ferait tant
l'union regarde
ce à dire que dans le milieu la saison
là c'est super ça cette verticale d'un
rappel et verticale comme ça voilà dans
les camions en ligne et bien